Nos piden graficar la función
"f" de "x" igual a "-3x" al cuadrado más 8.
Lo que vamos a hacer es tomar algunos valores de "x",
ver cuánto vale "f" de "x",
poner esos puntos en una gráfica
y después, pues más o menos extrapolar,
o sea, conectar los puntos
para ver cómo se vería la gráfica en general.
Pero antes de hacer esto, me gustaría que pensáramos un poquito en cómo se va a ver la gráfica,
o sea qué tipo de gráficas será
si tenemos -3x al cuadrado más 8,
¿será una línea?
¿una parábola?
¿un círculo?
o algo así como muy extraño.
Bueno, resulta que va a quedar una parábola
y eso tiene que ver con que
esto es un polinomio de grado 2 ,
un polinomio cuadrático, vale.
Bueno, pero hay dos tipos de parábolas,
las parábolas pueden abrir hacia abajo,
ser más o menos como una u invertida,
o pueden abrir hacia arriba,
ser como una u, una u normal.
Bueno,
¿qué tipo de parábola será?
Pues como aquí tenemos un -3,
que es un coeficiente principal negativo,
resulta que la parábola va a abrir hacia abajo.
Bueno, entonces la intuición nos dice que
vamos a obtener una parábola que abre hacia abajo,
vamos a ver si sí es cierto.
Para esto déjame pintar aquí el eje "x",
el eje "x" es éste, el horizontal,
vamos a poner aquí el eje "x",
vamos a poner acá el eje "y"...
el eje "y",
y vamos a ver cuánto vale esta función
en algunos valores,
estos valores los voy a poner
en una tabla por acá.
¿va?,
entonces aquí tenemos,
este... una tabla donde aquí vamos a poner
los valores de "x" y acá los de "y",
recuerda que "y" va a estar dada por "f" de "x".
Bueno y esos valores que vamos a poner,
digo tiene que ser una muestra del dominio
y el dominio son todos los reales,
pero no nos conviene que sean muy grandes,
porque si no pues va a ser muy complicado
evaluar la función ahí.
Así que déjame poner que los valores,
en los cuales vamos a evaluar la función "f" son -2,
- 1
y 2
¿va?
Antes de poner la escala en "y",
déjame llenar la tabla,
para que sepamos más o menos
hasta dónde tengo que llegar ¿va?
Bueno, entonces,
déjame empezar con "x" igual a -2,
si "x" es igual a -2
¿cuánto vale "y"?
Pues "y" es "f" de "x" y "f" de "x" está dada
por esta expresión de acá,
entonces nos quedaría -3,
multiplicado por 2 al cuadrado,
más 8, vale.
¿Cuánto es esto de acá?
esto es -3 por -2 al cuadrado,
-2 al cuadrado es 4
-3 por cuatro es -12
y si a -12 le sumamos 8, nos quedan -4.
Muy bien,
voy a seguir llenando la tabla.
Voy a poner aquí el -1,
¿qué nos quedaría?
nos quedaría -3 multiplicado por -1 al cuadrado más 8
-1 al cuadrado es 1, -3 por 1 es -3,
entonces este de aquí sería igual a 5.
Muy bien,
déjame pasar al color morado...
para ver "x" igual a 0,
entonces si "x" es igual a 0,
"f" de "x" es -3 por 0 más 8
-3... bueno, por 0 al cuadrado
más 8, esto de aquí es un 0,
aquí nos queda igual a 8.
Muy bien,
déjame continuar con otros dos valores,
voy a poner aquí el 1,
nos quedaría -3 por 1 al cuadrado más 8,
1 al cuadrado es 1,
-3 por 1 es -3,
aquí nos queda igual a 5
mira cómo que ya empieza a ser simétrico
alrededor del 0, verdad,
y finalmente...
finalmente déjame ponerle "x" igual a 2.
Si "x" es igual a 2
nos queda -3 por 2 al cuadrado más 8,
y esta cuenta ya la habíamos hecho,
es la misma que acá, porque 2 al cuadrado,
es lo mismo que -2 al cuadrado,
vaya, nos queda
-3 por 4 que es -12 más 8 que es -4
-4, muy bien.
Ya teniendo los valores en "y"
ahora sí
podemos dar una escala adecuada en el eje "y",
para que la gráfica nos quede bonita.
Entonces,
pues tenemos que llegar hasta 8 en los positivos
y hasta -4 en los negativos,
así que nos conviene
poner el 8 más o menos por acá.
Ahí está el 8,
entonces el 4 estaría a esta altura,
y el -4 sería el reflejado del 4
con respecto al 0,
o sea quedaría más o menos como por acá,
más o menos como por acá, -4,
sale,
entonces si éste es 8, este de acá es 6,
este de acá es 2,
este de acá es el 0,
lo voy a poner aquí,
por aquí tenemos 1, 3, 5 y 7,
por acá menos -2, -1 y -3 ¿vale?
Bueno, ahora sí, ya teniendo los ejes etiquetados
y con la escala adecuada
vamos a pasar
cada uno de estos puntos aquí, al plano,
entonces el primero,
es el punto -2, -4
-2, -4
es este punto de acá
muy bien, luego tenemos el -1, 5
tenemos el -1, 5
sería este punto de por acá, vale,
por aquí está el 5,
entonces éste es el...
déjame...déjame
ponerle sus coordenadas el -1, 5
este de acá es el -2, -4
-2, -4, muy bien.
luego tenemos el 0, 8
el 0, 8 que queda por acá,
este es el 0, 8...
eso parece un 6
deja de ponerle más bonito el 0.
Muy bien este es el punto morado,
vamos al punto azul,
el punto azul está en 1, 5
1, 5
y recuerda,
todos estos puntos que estoy pintando,
el hecho de que los esté pintando,
es que quiere decir
que están en la gráfica de la función,
de hecho por eso los estoy pintando,
para hacerme una idea de cómo se ve,
1, 5
finalmente déjame poner este de acá,
el 2, -4 que sería este punto de por aquí,
más o menos,
vale, el 2, -4
y ahora sí,
ya que tenemos estos 5 puntos
pues podemos, más o menos, hacernos una idea
de cómo se ve la gráfica de la función,
o sea nos ayudan, a pues ver
más o menos cómo está la cosa, verdad.
Entonces necesitamos una curva que una a estos cinco,
déjame tomar el color blanco...
para más o menos trazar lo que nos queda...
Entonces nos queda más o menos una curva de este estilo.
Viene por acá...
llega a este punto...
luego se empieza a aplanar...
y
y después es simétrica, empieza bajar así...
pasa por este punto...
y luego tiene que bajar un poco más rápido
para alcanzar ese de allá
Más o menos algo de
este estilo.
Muy bien, entonces esto está padre, verdad,
esto coincide con nuestra intuición,
aquí ya tenemos la gráfica de la función
que de hecho continúa...
continúa...
y lo importante es que esta línea no sólo tiene los cinco puntos muestra que pusimos
sino que además tiene todos los puntos que están
en el dominio de la función,
o sea tiene todos los puntos
correspondientes a la gráfica, vale.
Muy bien, entonces nos queda esta cosa de acá,
es una parábola, eso está fantástico,
porque coincide con la intuición
que habíamos agarrado desde aquí.